our next guest is a great actor you saw
him in the Pirates of the Caribbean
movies and most recently as one of the
men plotting against Jennifer kulage in
the second season of The White Lotus his
new series is Feud capot versus the
swans it starts January 31st on FX and
streams the next day on Hulu please
everybody Welcome Tom
[Applause]
[Music]
Hollander
okay I hate to be this American but just
cuz you're from a similar place but do
you know each other yes okay you do yeah
okay I always feel like a tool asking
but it's a large island yeah no it's
actually we we share mutual friends okay
yeah yeah you
seem you seem just thck as
them do you do you cook I do yeah yeah
oh you do you do you love what was the
hesitancy do you suck at cooking or no
I'm brilliant at it but I love doing it
yeah oh you do yeah I love it yeah oh
that's so good for you I never used to
and then and then uh kind of Co happened
and then so we were all at home and then
so that was the time and I I I do the
cooking in in our house which I love
doing and Jamie is um on my shelf yeah
you should get the five ingredients I've
got the five ingredients okay it's
pretty good yeah I also tried to do the
mayonnaise a few weeks ago yeah where
you put it on the towel and you put it
in an angle in the bowl okay what and
I've done I I have no idea I love it I
love it I love it you damage this is
like when people come and quote lines
therapy yeah quote lines to me from
things that I've done and I can't
remember them you're all the same that
happened to me with songs even if I
wrote it you did a really good recipe
for mayonnaise yeah I couldn't make it
work but you had 20 books can't remember
them all yeah and the poach chicken
remember the post chicken yeah that I
love that do you I have to ask cuz for
an actor it must be fun to play a bad
guy cuz you were like a bad guy in White
Lotus was that is that super fun for you
yeah I mean bad guys are fun sure
because you get to do things everyone
thinks of doing but nobody really can do
but you want to do yeah but everyone
goes no I mustn't do that because I'll
go to jail but if you're playing if
you're playing uh one of those
characters you get to do it yeah and the
devil the devil has the best Tunes as
they say well I want to I want to talk
about we love White Lotus but I do want
to talk about capot versus the swan so
how how did you get into this like is
this was this a role you were very
excited about playing oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah um I mean I got into it CU they
they they you know they I auditioned and
they asked me to do it but um the the uh
uh and then I went yippe because it's
he's such an amazing character yeah
truma kapot and he's also very strange
and sounds uh very unique and physically
is very unique so there's a lot of
transformation to do and I had to are
you going to are you going to show a
clip of it yes yes just because yes do
you want me to or no is it is this like
a tease I don't want to build it up too
much in case in case the audience goes
that looks well tell everybody before we
do that tell everybody a little about
the series if they don't know it's Feud
it's the second season of Ryan Murphy's
Feud mhm the um did you see the first
one the first one was yes so amazing um
Betty Davis and Joan Crawford so this
one is about Trum MC kabot falling out
with the high society ladies that he was
very very close to and then upset a lot
when he betrayed them all their secrets
by writing a a not very nice article in
Esquire magazine and they they kind of
canceled him and uh kicked him out and
he he needed them much more than he
realized or and was sort of
brokenhearted and then spent the rest of
his life um going on chat shows being
drunk going to Studio 54 or not writing
and kind of a slow decline um once again
another fun character to play well um he
is quite funny that's the thing he
managed to make jokes all the time on
the way down well we have a clip here's
Tom Hollander in Feud capot versus the
swans I know about you I know about your
car
accident shattered your
cheekbones how when they rebuilt your
face you were suddenly more beautiful
than ever you became a swan from an ugly
duckling am I right how do you know
about all that well my point
is the accident was a
blessing and now there's something
else you have a new best
friend oh my God the transformation of
you even your tone like your voice
everything like was that everything like
on did you have to like study that
person just to really mimic that you
sound completely different yeah well I
watched him on TV a lot cuz he did all
these these amazing experiences on the
way down exactly some of which were just
painful to watch cuz he went on when
he'd been up for two days and um and I
had an amazing voice coach called Jerome
Butler who's a dear man and a bit of a
genius and you listen you listen to it
for ages and then you sort of mimic like
a parrot and then you and then you have
to get beyond the parrot phase and try
and be a human being which happens and
eventually you're in it and then it
becomes in your muscles and you remember
it like you remember if you're learning
to dance or something and you learn a
dance movie you don't have to think
about it anymore it gets like that but
it's incredible you are incredibly
gifted you're such a great actor I love
anything you're in I love watching
you're so good thank you well that's
very kind of you I'm just being honest I
wouldn't not every day you get the not
every day you get asked to do one way
you can transform like that the thing to
have the ability to be able often you're
asked to play something that more or
less resembles who who you are when you
walk into the room so it's fun for fans
I wish people would let actors Branch
out musicians Branch out from their one
genre that they're used to seeing
because it's fun for us to see like
everybody wearing different hats yeah
and being it makes you feel more
creative that's kind of yeah exactly
that's what you sign up
[Music]
for
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home